Vào tri vui quân sự tình ra lại cho biết, bán tri vui phòng thuộc khu vực năm
ai uân pa đã kích thời ký vộ người dân bị cô lập gió mưa lũ
trước đó, mưa lớn trong nhiều ngày qua đã khiến mực nước sối U.A.
Rộn qua thuân E.A. giúp dân cao, bá vui cô lập nhiều người dân
trước tình hình vật quá khả năng ứng phó của địa phương
chính quyền sá U.A đã đến nghĩ hỗ trợ
bán tri vui phòng thuộc khu vực năm
ai uân pa đã trình thái bà sèu tô một số mấy
bà mùi hai cán bộ, đồng thời chỉ đạo bán tri vui quân sự xá U.A.
tham yêu cho địa phương trên thái lực lượng, phương tiện,
thuy động mùi muốn dân quân để phối hợp ứng cứu hình cấp
sau gần hai tiếng đồng vô, bà công dân đồng tiền đã được đưa về bởi bởi anh toàn
mở dọng phản vi tìm kiếm, tổ công tác tiếp tục phát hiện mùi công dân khác
đang bị cô lập trong giấy và đã tổ chức cứu vô anh toàn.
trong đật thình tài vừa qua trên địa bà n' xá U.A.
vẫn còn mỗi mi chính hộ, mỗi hai trăm bà mi tám nhân khẩu, miện gặp.
Sa đã tổ chức dây dời hai trà phổ dân đến ở tạm,
tại trường Trung Hoặc phổ thông, mwyn su.
Chên địa bà, vẫn còn một số khu vực nước trải sét về chia cấp và khó khăn cho công tác tiếp cận cứu chợp.